good afternoon
it is my extraordinary pleasure to
introduce to you today's speaker
professor akmaluddin
Asano Lu since 2005
professor Asano Lu has been the
Secretary General of the Organization of
Islamic Cooperation his association with
the OIC
dates back to 1980 when he was the
founding director general of the
Research Centre for Islamic history
culture and art in Istanbul
professor Asano lu has pioneered efforts
to create greater awareness about
Islamic culture across the world through
research publications the organizing of
congress's in various fields including
history of art science and intercultural
relations
he has also initiated and supervised
programs for the protection and
promotion of the written and the
architectural heritage of the Islamic
civilization in various countries around
the world
he's also contributed to scholarly
debates on intercultural dialogue
professor dr. Asano Liu was born in
Cairo Egypt he received his BS a Time
chumps University and his master's
degree in chemistry after completing his
PhD studies at Ankara University he did
his postdoctoral research at the
University of Exeter in the UK he has
served as a faculty member in the
Faculty of Sciences and then became the
first professor and founding head of the
apartment of the history of science at
Istanbul University he is also the
founding chairman of the Turkish Society
for the history of science
he further served as the president of
the International Union of history and
philosophy of science and is a member of
various international societies
scientific councils advisory boards
numerous Academy centers and Institute's
and editorial boards around the world
professor Asano Lu is also very much
involved I'm happy to say with Columbia
University we're proud that Columbia
University Press in 2010 published one
of his many books and in fact the title
of the book is the title of today's talk
the Islamic world in the new century
in addition professor ISA Nalu is one of
the founding members of the advisory
board of the Columbia University Global
Centre in Istanbul to which he is
devoted an enormous amount of time and
shared his expertise with us as we
attempt to build the kinds of creative
cultural and intellectual relationships
that represent so much the ethos and the
spirit of Professor Asano Lu's career it
is my absolute pleasure and privilege to
introduce to you professor if melody in
his son
ladies and gentlemen distinguished
scholars students colleagues and the
distinguished audience of this wonderful
academic evening it's really great to be
back to academia after the long hustle
in matok affairs and the corridors of
United Nations and I'm grateful to the
host to the University of Columbia and
to organizer the Istanbul branched
outreach in Istanbul and it's very
active director mrs. epic gem da and her
colleagues and to our hosts today here
and I thank him for the wonderful words
kind words he mentioned Islamic world in
the new century it's not only the title
of my book which has published by day it
couldn't be any worse the press two
years back but it's it's a very
interesting issue for all of us as we
all go through difficult times difficult
times particularly for last two weeks or
10 days we have been witnessing this
tense relation between Muslim world or
parts of the Muslim world and the parts
of the Western world extreme extremists
on the two sides are giving us a
difficult time it's also it's
interesting to see how the Muslim world
will take its place in the new order to
be shaped as the balance between powers
has been changing since demise of the
Soviet Union
the end of the Cold War the downfall of
Berlin Wall and the awakening of nations
all over the world it's also interesting
for us all belonging to different parts
of the East and West and becoming here
under this roof of very distinguished
academic institution Columbia University
with many chairs for Islamic studies
Turkish studies Arab studies
international studies to know better
about the dynamics of the Muslim world
today the mentioned book has been
published few months before what
happened in the Arab world before boys
easy set himself to fire and the whole
story started to unfold from Tunisia to
Egypt to Libya to Yemen to Bahrain to
Syria and still unfortunately not did
not end in enforcing in the subject of
the book was not really a it's only it
was not a reference book at all I see
how it came to being which were the
historical background since the fall of
the Caliphate and attempts of Muslim
leaders intellectuals and political
movements to establish a kind of enter
or in terms lamech organization it was
not only that or not only studying the
rivalry between the so-called
progressive camp in the Arab world and
the the backward camp in their world or
by the socialist nation a list and
monarchist as it was explained or
understood in those days it was also an
attempt to see how oh I seek Him as
an organization stands for south-south
as an organization which represent a
aspirations and the hope for one and
half billion people in that book I said
that the Muslim world aspires to regain
its long-lost status and strives to be a
part of mainstream global community
tackling contemporary concerns and
working towards development in all
fields moreover it yearns to benefit
from the universal values of freedom
liberty good governance justice and
human rights and hopes to rejoice in the
blessing of progress and prosperity that
was the words I mentioned before what
has been known wrongly in my
understanding as an Arab Spring better
call it Arab Awakening or awakening of
the Muslim world as a part of the
International awaking or I would if we
won't need to to make an arab adjective
to it we have to say it is Arab autumn
it's the fall of dictators but it's not
the spring yet Spring has to come after
long winter and autumn autumn and winter
then the wind the spring will come as
the realization of democratic process
formulation of political power political
parties establishment of constitutional
system etc etcetera so this is what I
has seen for seen just before the things
happened and I would like to say that oh
I see in its history and for
his future will stand in the eyes of
many as a symbol of unity as a framework
representing centuries-old concept of
OMA slam Ikoma the worldwide community
of Muslims forged through bonds of faith
although this outlook is manifest stated
differently throughout the Muslim world
a common spirit stemming from a long
shared history and traditions deeply
rooted in the common faith supports this
understanding people's expectation from
though I see generally rise to peak
during periods when their own countries
or Muslims in general face problems and
I think we are facing one problem today
so in reality the OIC came into being as
a South South relationship in when we
look to late 60s and early 70s when they
were term to loss political and
ideological changes that set the scene
for oh I see evolution over the decades
the development efforts of the
relatively new States because in 60s and
70s you have new relatively new
independent states these new states
well part tried to be part of a bargain
between the North and the South the
Muslim countries were all part of the
south and what what became known as a
developing world and most still are they
strove for equal opportunities with the
north a new world business and struggle
to achieve economic growth and
industrialization in this effort they
increase in these thought ways to
cooperate among themselves in order to
increase mutual trade and investment and
to solve common problems through
bilateral and multilateral arrangements
ideas and actions were developed by were
deployed by developing countries around
the theme of economic cooperation for
development
more recently the expansion of global
economy from the 1990s involving the
entry of very many more people into the
world market and trade has had and
continues to have tangible effects on
Muslim countries these trends have
engaged engendered a strong awareness
amongst Muslim countries in the 21st
century of their populations greater
needs an expectation for economic growth
and prosperity this requires the removal
of obstacles in the way of social
mobility and advancement the achievement
of sustainable development and
democratization of political system the
founding goals now have found new
formulations in the term and contest
context of the 21st century these
perhaps were the background of how oh I
see came into being apart from the
classic narration of 1990 69 and the
burning of al-aqsa mosque for sure it
they were the reason or that was the
reason
but behind that they were very
deep-rooted economic social and
political demands of these nations
having said that on how the OIC came
into being let me say at least for my
own experience as a secretary and before
that as a DG of one of wise institutions
tell you about how member countries what
they expect from why I see the
expectation of the member states of what
I see differ from one country to another
and I'll shape primarily by two
considerations among is a wider
landscape of complex determinants this
wider context include the motives that
led to the establishment of YC which
will be detailed which I detailed this
in different chapters of the book it
also includes obligation to meet
people's needs and aspirations as
already I have elaborated but there are
two consultations which I would like to
underline here first consultation ose
creates the possibility of obtaining
political support and cooperation from
the Muslim world on the basis of the
very notion of the result data oh I see
what we call Islamic solidarity this
especially the case in situations where
eliciting support and cooperation can be
challenging within the framework of
other intergovernmental organizations
such as the United Nations owing to the
delicate international political power
balances in which the United Nation
operates cannot allow the support
certain countries are looking forward
examples are given examples through the
book show that this demand for political
support has been met very successfully
in some cases while in others it has
remained
as an expression of moral support in
both cases the governments of member
states would present the success
obtained - though I see - their
populations as an important achievement
and you can find this in reporting after
meetings of mysterion meetings me summit
meetings when the minister farmers over
the head of state or head of the
government attends and comes back to his
country declaring that he has got a
great support from OIC
to his or her own problem which he never
get the support from other international
organization the second consolation in
and what shapes the primary
considerations for the member countries
the second one is economic I already
explained part of that in the relation
between north south south south heel the
majority of oh I see countries are non
industrial countries 22 of them are
least developed countries these
governments have invested hopes in the
economy programs of OSE and its
affiliated institutions particularly the
Islamic Development Bank which is one of
the most successful developed banks in
the world and has create programs for
helping building infrastructure social
and economic development programs in OSE
countries it has been successful doing
that and since 2005 since I became
secretary and then we adopted the
10-year program action there are certain
special programs for Africa for poverty
alleviation funds and other funds which
benefiting these countries so this is
the second consideration for many the
greatest expectation placed in though I
see is that it will act as a forum to
address common concerns as well as a
platform for action
as we as will be outlined it has been
outlined in different chapter of the
book the OIC agenda expanded from the
average days on word and increasingly
enforced the cops of concept of all
compassing cooperation by that the end
of the first decade of activities this
understanding came to be expressed in
the term joint Islamic action though
decisions are generally taken by
consensus and shaped by positions
adopted by politically and economically
influential member states it is worth
noting here that also by consensus
though I see has been able to develop
effective policies on some issues to
which public opinion in Muslim countries
is more sensitive and that this decision
have been influenced national politics
for instance one of the issues that
enters the public opinion in the Muslim
countries the Islamophobic movements and
now we're going through a very difficult
sensitive time nowadays after this nasty
obnoxious film made by obscure guided
misguided people and nobody knew about
them until they put it in the in the
Internet and nobody noticed that and
since some other guided people on the
other side of the world discovered this
and made an issue of it and started to
agitate people to make demonstrations to
put on fire embassies and unfortunately
to kill people and to kill themselves
we know I see of course condemned all
these and we have shown we have invited
people to constrain self constrain and
to be calm and try to come down the
streets and we publish many statements I
also published a joint statement with
the High Representative Reserve High
Representative opinion Union
Cathy Ashton and secretary of Arab
League and African Union calling people
to calm down and not to take the law in
their hands and Cotto
condemning the both events here
oh I see zero comes in the four and we
have been working on this with European
Union with the United States since mr.
president Bush administration and
through President Obama's administration
until we reached a joint decision
resolution in Human Rights Council in
2011 a well known resolution by 1618 and
we hope to build on this and further
develop this understanding of fighting
extremism on both sides and forming a a
mechanism for addressing these issues so
the this is the role which oh I see is
trying to do I just want to give you one
example before I touch on other issues
relevant to I see and the Muslim model
21st century one example good example of
how the proactive approach of why I see
affected the relationship between member
countries in 2005 there was an
exothermic summit in December in the
holy city of Mecca and it was an
invitation of the of the monarch of
Saudi Arabia King Abdullah for the 4x
ordinance ummat and then we presented a
10-year program action this was the
first time in history Isis such program
among many projects and programs we have
targeted increasing the inter trade
between OIC countries let me tell you
that inter trade in 2004 just before the
summit was around 2005 billion dollars
interest rate thought value of total
inter or IC treat was 2 so 205 thought
105 billion dollars last year 2011 the
value of total intro I see trade has
reached 680 so in seven years it went
more than three times that shows to some
extent these projects and programs are
effective now if we look to today's
Muslim world the Muslim world today at
the beginning of the second decade of
the 21st century as going through an
awakening period until recently most of
the people in this part of the world
were neither politically conscious nor
politically active
they were either passive politically or
repressed and this was the case in many
countries the awakening happened after
the end of the Cold War the end of the
Soviet system the fall down of Berlin
Wall awakening started in Central Europe
East Europe and other parts of the world
was lead to come to the Arab world and
the Muslim world I don't forget it did
not start with Tunisia when my book was
in the printing house what happened in
Kyrgyzstan as we call it in Turkish or
Kaguya it is called in in Russian and
other languages this happened in summer
2010 first time in Central Asia people
awaken people politically they took the
street and the force of the dictator a
soviet-style dictator to abandoned the
country
and to fled to Belarus or wherever he
went and within very short period which
we helped them as I see they transformed
to a constitutional system multi-party
system and they had the first elected
parliament and first elected president
that was mid 2010 in December 2010 the
you know the famous story of vegetable
vendor poor was easy in a small town in
Tunisia and then the whole awakening of
the Arab world started with this poor
man putting himself to fire in protest
to the said of the bad cruel
treatment here you see from the
municipality and people started to walk
to Street and then this the regime has
collapsed it in a very short period then
events in Egypt happened and events and
she would have not happened without
Tunisia doing that so the chain reaction
started the other late in the Muslim
world from kirgizia to Tunisia Tunisia
happen its own each bit would have not
happened in its own without Tunisia
happening I will not forget an Egyptian
lady talking to one of those satellite
channels saying that if they did it in
an Tunisia here in Egypt
omma dunya we have to do it so that is
the chain reaction started so this
awakening now brings with it a host of
issues this awakening first of all we
have to understand that it was a
cumulative product
of an internationally interdependent
world connected by instant visual
communication and demographically pushed
by youth dynamism you have three factors
who fused in one the national resentment
political awakening and ideological
formation in the new ideological
formation where Islam plays a role we
have to look carefully to the position
of Islam in the new polity at the end of
the first decade of the 21st century the
consensus is far from being reached and
controversy still persists over the
position and weight of religion as a
frame of reference in the internal and
external affairs of the Muslim countries
the place and affect of Islam in Muslim
societies and the way the faith is
reflected in their relations with the
wider international community depend
upon where and how each country draws
the line between religion and politics
Muslims are not alone in debating this
point particularly as the role of faith
in contemporary society becomes one of
the pressing issues of our time however
it is not it is worth noting that Islam
as a religion has a different place in
the workings of society compared to
other religions and if we don't
understand this difference we will be in
trouble and that makes some things not
more simple it makes things more
difficult we have to understand Islam
occupied a distinct place in the polity
from its advent until the abolition of
Caliphate in
19:24 and if in failure to understand
and acknowledge this this has often
resulted in misleading interpretations
and theories about the Muslim world and
lead to a superficial understanding of
Islam disregarding its real cultural and
religious aspects the danger is that
these analysis have influenced
politicians and intellectuals both
outside and inside Muslim countries
Muslim countries have experienced a
diverse scale of politics and
ideological landscape reflects that
experience at one end of the spectrum
some Islamic or Islamist regimes have
embraced the strictest possible
interpretation and practices of Islam at
the other end
some secularists regimes have denied
Islam any role in governance a third
middle path has been adopted by other
Muslim countries with variations among
them are countries whose constitution
constant contains a clause declaring
Islam as a major source of legislation
in all these three groups all these
three groups many countries in all these
three groups many countries constitute
constitutions adopt the principle of
patria or belonging to the same
Heartland homeland as the umbrella that
covers all citizens without distinction
as to race or region in opposition to
all these trends there are radical
political movements which uses lamb to
justify their repugnant and illegitimate
practices
one of the main acquisition labeled
against Islam on the international scene
is based on unjustified and unfounded
linking of practices of this illegal
radical political movements with Islam I
have written this just before events
happened now after what happened in the
Middle East the the relationship between
Islam and politics is becoming rather a
subject of bigger discussion and the
future of the Muslim world depends on to
a large extent on the articulation and
development of the principles of good
governance together with the
establishment of a tradition of
pluralistic democratic practices to be
sure there is no easy undertaking to do
this it entails unflinching preserve
once as it is likely to span more than a
generation what happened in the Arab
world what has been called as spring is
a misleading notion because if you're
celebrating the arrival of spring then
you're expected to see the blossoming of
flowers and the end of the day you will
get the fruit but here it is not the
case as I said this is the this is the
downfall of dictators this is the autumn
of despots so the process the
democratization the way to get the Arab
Spring or the spring in the Muslim world
is likely to spend more than a
generation in their recent history many
Muslim countries have not at all
experienced democracy in the modern
sense of this who
odd similarly those Muslim countries
that have lived through some form of
democratic governance has suffered
setbacks and confronted crises that have
simply cut short the Democratic
experiences this happened before 1950
yet Islamic heritage and history are
full of memorable instance instances of
good governance and that the immutable
principles that uphold it we hardly
believe that there is no fundamental
dissonance between the application of
puristic democracy and the foundation of
good governance in Islam looking back to
the middle of the lusts of the 19th
century the last century of the Ottoman
Empire we see clearly that it embraced a
modern Constitution and founded a
parliament along with other institutions
that are the hallmarks of a modern state
during these periods prominent Muslim
scholars and leaders saw no conflict or
disparity between these modern
institutions on the one hand and the
traditions of Islam and its fundamental
principles of governance on the other
better still a significant number of
those scholars and eminent Muslim
figures actually contributed and
participated in building of the
foundation of modern institutions and
that was during the last decades of the
Ottoman Sultanate Ottoman Caliphate
Ottoman Empire whatever you called it
considering that the road to democracy
was never paved with roses in those
countries with longstanding traditions
of democracy of democratic governance we
admit that democratization as stated
above cannot be achieved without
establishing two critical principles the
first principle is good governance
and transparency at the level of public
affairs management and the
implementation of accountability the
second is the need to allow political
freedoms to be ingrained in the
well-established roles of human rights
without these two vital principles the
sole outlet of the politically actively
active in the Muslim societies will be
to seek to achieve their ambitions by
falling back into the religious sphere
this scenario if it unfolds will
eventually complicate matters and make
them worse than they are already in
order for the Muslim societies to move
result ly down the path of progress they
need to define the relationship between
the religious and the political without
letting one intrude on to the other the
relationship should be based on mutual
respect allowing and accepting purism
and also allowing change and transition
in political powers through Democratic
means Muslim societies ought to lift the
control exercised by the religious over
the political and vice versa they need
they need to clear to clearly determine
the demarcation line between the two I
would like to say that in NYC the
10-year program of action and the new
Charter which has been accepted in 2008
they call universal values of democracy
good governance human rights
the woman rights empowerment of women
society caring for child rights
development R&D
search and development encouraging
certain science and technology all these
values have been advocated and we think
that oh I see as an agent of moderation
and modernization within though I see
country with the Muslim mode as an agent
of moderation and modernization and
internationally as a global actor for
constructive cooperation would as a
responsible partner would be would be a
catalyst for development would be
catalysts for creating a better
understanding between the Muslim world
and the rest would be an agent as I said
for modernization and moderation within
the Muslim world and hopefully if the
leadership or the developing leadership
now in certain countries accept this new
ethos of why I see I hope that our
future will be much better than our
history I thank you for your patience
and I didn't want to carry on I think
just about time allocated to me and I
would appreciate if you have any
interesting showing in raising certain
questions
thank you so much we don't have that
long for questions but I would ask that
you be absolutely and totally brief so
that we can get as many questions and as
possible there are microphones on each
side we're going to take two questions
at a time state your name and the
division to which you are linked beside
hi i'm lotus i'm in this full of general
studies my question has to do with the
clash of ideologies between the west and
the middle east one of them you touched
on a little bit is uh the is democracy
and how and i and how i've gathered that
it's in certain instances iraq
afghanistan is being forced on the
country's i'm not completely convinced
that democracy is what everyone or most
people want in the middle east but but
that's just an example of the clash i
guess my main my main the question part
of that is how do we reduce this clash
and obviously there's examples dialogue
interaction humanism and obviously we
need more than one of these but what do
you think is the most effective and what
do you think how do you think we should
prioritize this reduction of clashing
great and where should the resources go
thank you other question number two
we're gonna take two at a time all right
your name i'm kevin bow from columbia
college great and my question is there
currently exists an unfortunately
negative view of the islamic world in
many parts of the globe right now and
that view is vastly incorrect based on
limited knowledge and my question to you
is on an individual level on a communal
level and on an international level
what can people do to change and create
a more create a more accurate image of
the Muslim world today thank you so the
first question is really the issue of
whether there really is a clash between
the cultures of the West and Islamic
cultures and if there is how do we
overcome the tensions that exist now in
various parts of the Islamic world well
I really don't think there is a clash
between Islam and the West not on any
reason but when you first of all we have
to analyze what Islam stands for and
West stems its roots of civilization I
think we have two common roots we have
to emphasize these common roots and then
we have a shared history the common
roots if Christianity is the basis of
the most Western world
we share with the Christianity the
brahmic tradition and you don't find
these values between say the West and
the Far East or between Islam and
forests so we have shared value in a
brahmic tradition belonging to the same
divine source if you believe in it as a
believer but if you don't believe in it
as a believer you have to take it as
historical reality the second one which
is not too much it's very simple fact of
history but it's not too much discussed
the Greek philosophy and the ancient
sciences it was the Muslim world who
inherited Greek philosophy and science
and developed it
and then this went from Muslim world
from through Andalusia Cecilia and other
parts the Arabic translation of Greek
sources was translated from arabic to
latin and you cannot understand thomas
aquinas without understanding Avalos you
cannot understand Newton or Copernicus
without understanding him the shuttle or
Bedini Shirazi you cannot understand
Harvey without understanding Avicenna so
the what is known as scientific
revolution the basis of modern culture
and modern Western society is based on
Islamic sciences and philosophy which is
also took its sources as it took from me
from many other sources because Islamic
Islamic science and philosophy or
Islamic civilization took root from
Greek Hellenistic from Persian from
Indian and from Chinese ancient
civilizations and then assemble this and
this went to the west and translated and
it was this books after being translated
to Latin they were were part and parcel
of the curricula in the European
universities and without the the average
school intern in Padua they would have
not been a Christian theology so these
two roots Abrahamic root and what I call
or we can call Greek root then the
interchange between Islam and the the
European civilization through the
Mediterranean through translations to me
so we have so many in common the problem
we have today is twofold
one is political and I'm sure you know
that and the second is that we are both
suffering from extremists on two sides
radicals so it is not radical it is not
a clash of civilization it is not a
clash of religions it is not clash of
faiths or culture or whatever it is
clash of ignorant people
it is clash of of radical people on two
on two sides and we as a mainstream
people we as a millions and billions of
people we should know we should not be
the captives or we should not be the
victims of this radical people and and I
think that follows up very much to the
second question then given the pervasive
negative views of Islam and you'd find
that as you move around the United
States that there are frequently very
extreme positions how do we overcome
that level of ignorance both on the
individual the communitarian and the
international level well let me tell you
that it looks that these small groups on
both sides I think I would put those who
made this obscure foe on the same on the
same grade or the same level of those
who went to burn the embassy or killed
ambassador both are terrorists one is
abusing the right of expression the
freedom of putting releases on the
Internet to inside to hatred
knowing that whatever he is doing is
going to provoke these ignorant people
on the other side of the sea or the
ocean and then those people whose who
immediately said this is America
Americans not go and kill them bust or
or or burn the flag I put these two
people but here we are we are in
Colombia
diversity if you go to the publication
house you will find the hands of book
written on the contribution of Muslim to
the Satuday to the world civilization
you in I'm sure in different departments
of history philosophy of religion you
all studying this and if you can go to
the internet you'll find hundreds of
sources thousands of them but the
problem that this vocal small group the
damage they make they can they can
destroy whatever we have been doing for
decades we in though I see in 1990s 1999
initiated the dialogue of civilizations
United Nations and then seven years ago
Turkey and Spain jointly they created
what has been called alliance of
civilizations we have been working on
similar programs and we have reached
these consensual resolutions with the
united states with the european union
with the rest of the world and we had a
lot of work doing in all diplomatic for
and then all of a sudden obscure man
call group comes and makes this film and
then they put the whole world on fire so
we really have to unite against these
mad people and you know young people
here and you're doing in your
dissertations in your works and your
papers you have also to address the
masses it's not an ivy in an ivory tower
that we sit and discuss these issues we
have to address the masses and media
here mass media is has the biggest
responsibility to these people this is
unfortunately is not happening on white
skin on the contrary they will give long
hours for this bad deeds and they will
not give short time or short hours for
the good work you are doing what we are
trying to do this is all we can deal
with the people who are appear already
ah your question please
Sanofi I'm in Columbia College and my
question is how long do you think it
will take the government of countries
like Egypt and Syria to stabilize and be
on the right Democratic path and what
else does do the countries need to do in
order for this to happen
hope look great and hello my name is
Alma Shana I am a Turkish first year
student studying in Columbia engineering
school my question is about a relatively
less mainstream topic we're always
talking about Islam the Muslim world and
Western countries relations but there
are also complex inside the Islamic
world between shiahs and sunnis and the
public has forgotten the inner conflict
of islam while we're talking about the
developments in the arab world what do
you think about the inner conflicts
inner political conflicts of Islam and
how does oh I see a break to solve this
conflict because without solving this
problem it is hard to integrate with
Western civilization's in my opinion
thank you
the first question how do we remedy the
dilemmas in Egypt and Syria in terms of
the probability democracy I'm not on
position to remedy it but I got the
question how long it will take I know
well I I think I'm in passing I mention
I said well look let's be frank
how many years democracy has took in
this country to be established or any
other country
how many generation generation it took
democracy I wouldn't give you an
American example or European I give you
an example of my country we have been
since Tanzimat it's more than 170 years
now in my country trying to change for
absolute monarchy - constitutional
monarchy from old fashioned institutions
institutions to modern students nation
and then I spoke about the first Ottoman
assembly which was established in 1876
and the second one in 1908 and then you
have constitutional first constitution
second Constitution and then you have
Republic and then you have dictatorial
regime under the public and then you
have multi-party system and you have we
had coup d'etat - military or for
military coup d'etat so it depends on
your definition and then we have hanged
our prime minister our speaker of
parliament or one of the brilliant our
ministers of office just because they
were democratic Democrats and they were
not liked by the junta so if a country
my country went through all this our
prime minister the compromise was put in
jail because he read a poetry written by
on a poet patriotic poet and it was a
schoolbooks it was nothing by communist
or fascist or whatever it is it's
well-known poetry were all kids in the
school so if if all these experience
tells us that the road to - to democracy
is not paved with roses it will take
much don't think that one election in
any country Egypt is experience election
free and unfair election first time
after 60 years 60 years with no election
there were elections 99.999% this were
the elections all the 60 years then they
became rational and said well it's iiep
to make it 100 percent almost make it 80
percent for 75 percent and they will do
it in the office now first time
this is a long way of trial and failure
but of course the process has started
nobody can reverse this process so this
is not spring yet this is a downfall
this is the autumn of despots of
dictators and the first the kindergarten
of democracy the second cause this is
very important issue I have addressed
this in and I give some examples about
this in my book now the existence of
different method let's use the
terminology the proper diplomas you must
have schools of thought or sure of
jurist of juridical school or doctrines
whatever you call it in in English sects
mess-ups the difference is there from
almost the first century of Asia of
Islamic era and this has been all
through the Islamic history the problem
is not between the maps themselves of
course there been religious discussions
books opinions and refutations and
rivalries between mess-ups etcetera but
this has been mainly academic debates
and they are all built on argumentation
disputation coating this verses from the
holocron or from the tradition of the
Prophet that he was praying this way or
putting his hand away or that this is
anyhow that was the case in the whole
history of Islam there are only few
times
where the political aspect was
was debtor mental in creating rivalry
between mess-ups it was not mass HAP's
who created rivalry between politicals
and one of them in in our own history
between the ottomans and safavids now
when you look to reality in the Middle
East of today in my generation we never
thought of an Iraqi man whose name is
Ahmed o Muhammad that he is she or Sunni
or or anything else
we never thought even have occurred or
Arab but after what happened in Iraq in
last decade and establishment of
sectarian system in Iraq a sectarian
politician and the Kota for she is for
Sunnis Arabs Kurds etcetera the whole
notion has changed now the war in Iraq
during the war in 2006 we endo I see in
2005 in Mecca cement we have introduced
a provision which has been in M ously
accepted equating 8 mess-ups for Sunni
mess ups Hanafi Shafi'i Maliki humbly
and - she mess-ups Joffrey and Zadie and
two other small mess-ups ybody and Zoe
and by the decision of the summit and
this is you can call this email the mat
she like they were equated now that was
December 2005 in October 2006 window I
see managed to bring 15 of the granuloma
of the Sunnis and 15 of the ayatollahs
and at allows mass and there
ts together under the umbrella YC and
made them after long negotiations sign a
document of 10 items and that was the
first time in the modern history such a
thing has been happened and that stopped
the killing and the fighting between
Sunnis and Shias in Iraq so oh I see has
managed to do this because we have
differentiated we took the political
aspect outside we concentrated on the
religious aspect and since the two are
getting their sources from the book and
the tradition of the Prophet it finishes
so there is no place for for fighting
fighting is there because there is
political parties political powers would
like to this yuzuru against this one and
they start fighting each other and
unfortunately this is what now unfolds
in Syria the Syrian people when they
took to the street they will mix it and
when it started on the government side
they will mix it and on the opposition
side they will mix it and I think they
are still mix it they still they are
still represent the whole spectrum of
Sunnis Shias Alois Christians Armenians
Turkmen skirts but this fight will make
this differentiation unfortunately and
this is what we are all against I
apologize but we are already 10 minutes
over and you can really do you've been
waiting and I wish we could continue but
please feel free to join His Excellency
and the rest of you at a reception that
will be held right behind me in the
Faculty room where you can hopefully
have a chance to ask your questions
thank you all very much and thank you
your excellency for a wonderful